[Music]
all right let's go out to Detroit Rock
City and talk to the great and wonderful
Ashley what's up Ashley Hi how are you
rocking on to the break it Dawn what are
you
doing um I'm just took a break to my
workday because I got this call this
morning that I get to be on and go over
the question I submitted yesterday
awesome hey um do me a favor talk
directly into your phone okay okay can
you hear me per perfect perfect okay all
right so what's up what have you done
now just
kidding so um I am struggling I'm an
emotional person so this hard I am too
it's all
good I'm struggling to be a single mom
um after a divorce and just finding my
place
as alone because I never saw myself
being um alone I'm a I'm in a relational
person like I I want to be in a
relationship I want to enjoy adventure
and fun with somebody and it's just I'm
really struggling with being alone what
happened to your
marriage
um kind of a long story but in the end
um I just don't I just think he fell out
of love with me um he ended it there was
a lot of there was a lot of trauma that
happened with um my side of the family
and some things that happened that he
wasn't happy with and he would support
me through wanting to support my family
and so we we buted heads a lot in that
in the end um but also ultimately I felt
like he was pulling away from me and um
was a very um avoidant and dismissive
person and so when we tried to go
through therapy resolving that and
saying needed more um really really I
was stuck on my love languages and that
I need affection and and words of
affirmation and he couldn't give that to
me I felt very alone and
so um I don't know if it was me pressing
that and you know at the end plus some
of the things that went on with um
conflict with our my extended family um
he filed in the
end did that surprise you did it
surprise you um no because he was kind
of that way in the beginning he was kind
of a he's in law enforcement and he was
just kind of a more of a stoic like
didn't show his affection but it just
felt like it got worse when
um I lost my dad traumatically and I
lost my brother traumatically and I just
felt very much alone in that and then
when he tried to say that he didn't want
anything to do with the rest of my
family because of something that my
brother had done um I just felt
abandoned I think and I think I'm still
struggling with that is there a chance
that that um yeah you should be
struggling with that that's hard is
there a chance that you left him
too
um I think he just filed the paperwork I
sign yes I did um he's the one that
filed initially and I begged him not to
do it but I know that when it was all
said and done um May of 2022 a huge
weight was lifted off my
shoulders because of how he treated me
so I know that I'm I was not with the
person that I that I would have wanted
to be with forever like I eventually I
might have ended things um but I wasn't
raised that way my parents were very
happily married so I I there's part of
me that feels like I failed and I failed
my kids um but I do know that I'm
happier now without him in my life okay
I just know it's causing me to struggle
with where I'm at being single and and
feeling
um there's a lot of different routes we
could
take give me a know there's a lot I know
there's a lot that's okay you're you're
not a lot Kelly Kelly is a lot you are
not a lot um so give me um like give me
a particular question we can work on
okay um I think more than anything being
okay with being single in this season
and being okay with who I am because I I
know that I struggle
with um my own identity and being okay
with who I am because I
think I there's still something there
with feeling like I wasn't enough for
him so I'm not enough for someone else
okay so those are two completely
different things all right the first
thing is if you're not if you're not
happy being single don't force yourself
to pretend that you're happy that you're
single it's okay to grieve that I miss
something
yeah and you miss just knowing that
somebody's in the house in case there's
a sound you miss sex you miss sharing a
meal with somebody you miss silliness
you probably even missed the conflict a
little bit just miss engagement right
yeah I wouldn't pretend that you're not
feeling that that's going to make you
insane right yeah or like to to give you
a picture if you take that feeling and
you don't want to feel
it like you press it down you shove it
down or you compress it another word for
that is to depress it right and your
body goes oh we got it those things
aren't good so we don't want to do that
right the second thing you're talking
about
confidence because you're asking
yourself the question what was so bad
about me that he wouldn't just say I
love you and give me a back rub what was
so bad about me right what was so bad
about me that when he was stressed at
work I wasn't his safe place to come um
like be be
with he was so bad about me that he
wouldn't be with me when my dad died and
my brother
died and that's a question of
confidence and so the hard the hardest
turn to make
is he didn't show up when my dad and my
brother died because something was wrong
with him not
me okay and confidence is not something
you can just whip up you can't just
imagine it
confidence is something you have to
practice okay your body knows the
difference we failed miserably with the
self-esteem movement right they studied
a whole bunch of CEOs and they saw that
these super successful people had
insane belief in
themselves and so what they tried to do
is go back and give that to kids just
tell kids they're wonderful stop having
trophies stop letting kids lose or get
second place we all win we're going to
we're going to we're going to inject
this AB this insane
self-confidence what they failed to
realize and we've got a generation that
grew up thinking that they're the
greatest thing that ever lived is those
CEOs gained that insane self-confidence
by failing a million times right and
getting beat up and beat up and they
kept dragging themselves to one more
step and one more step and one more step
so by the time they finally got to the
top of whatever Hill they were trying to
climb dude they were the most confident
guys in the world because they've been
dragged down so much and that's
different okay and so you got knocked
completely
over some by your own doing some by him
some by just the the nature of your
relationship man for whatever reason
couldn't sit down and say let's let's
dig into this yep so you have to go on a
journey to be
weird as how old are you 42 oh gosh
making friends at 42 the worst I have a
Amazing Friends honestly I do because
I've had a couple girlfriends who've
gone through divorce and they're my
rocks so I do have amaz I know hold on
but they can be your rock but I've hung
out with a bunch of divorced women
before
right yeah yes right and I've hung out
with divorced dudes before when there's
three or four of them it's like bro bro
and I just want to set my face on fire
to make sure I can still feel
right so it is good to have people who
have been there before who are like down
the road from you to get some wisdom
from but you also need people in your
life who still love the idea of Love
yeah and who are still actively seeking
connection and you're going to have to
just be weird about some of these
pictures you have in your head about
this is the way this works I just sit
idly by in my church pew and some guy
Taps me on the shoulder and says would
you and you're like I would like that's
not GNA happen I know right it's not
gonna happen so you're gonna have to be
weird you might have to ask somebody at
your office Place say you go get coffee
or somebody at the daycare center where
your kid works or your kid goes I I
don't I don't know your world or you
have to say hey I'm back on the market
ladies I've got to I've got to slowly
take little baby steps into this thing
and dating
is the absolute miserable worst it's
worse than making friends as I've been
told right it is I've tried yep okay so
remember back to those
CEOs it's you're going to have to just
decide I'm going to keep scratching and
clawing one more step one more step one
more step okay because you're practicing
confidence and let's be super super
honest um have you sat down and been
reflective on what role you played in
your
marriage um yes I've I've been through a
lot of therapy and
um I know that I was
codependent um I was a stay-at-home mom
for the last six years and I kind of
lost my myself
and um I know I played a role in that
way that I just felt um I was very
dependent on him at times
for my happiness instead of finding my
happiness somewhere else outside of just
him I don't think it's necessarily bad
to find happiness and to begin to lean
on your
spouse I don't think that's codependent
codependent is when I'm going to bury
myself in order to make sure they're
okay um and I did that too okay I was so
concerned with his needs and how I could
be better for him that I I kind I just
felt like I really let myself go got and
um you know I but I also think that I I
I created that in my mind because I
didn't have him telling me out anything
else that's fair I thought it wasn't
good enough for him because he wasn't
saying those things so I
think I'm not sure I'm not 100% sure
exactly what I did I guess so let me say
it like this um the only way marriage
works is if both people go all in like
in in a way that's insane it doesn't
make any sense right right like I am all
in on you this is it and you got to be
all in on me and when that doesn't work
or it falls
apart often the solution is kind of a
misguided definition of codependency
and that which basically means the next
time I'm going to go one foot in cuz I
always have to keep one foot on the
ground one foot in the boat's fine but
one on the ground to make sure that I'm
doing what I need to do so that I can
and I'm here to tell you that's not
going to work right what you have to do
is be willing to risk getting hurt this
bad again yeah and I think I am there
because I I am the kind of person that
um I wear my heart on my leave I tell
you how I I tell them how I feel you
know I've dated and I've been in a
couple you know shortlived relationships
and I feel like maybe like I always
question did I give too much did I tell
that person too much did I you know
share I I share a lot because I want
them to know everything about me and who
I am and what I'm willing to give so let
me tell you this you probably are a lot
and there is somebody who loves a
lot
and so walking away every time that's
just that anxiety spinning up on you I
said this I shouldn't have laughed like
that oh my gosh I ate this and I should
have put my Fork down like that right
what I want you to take full ownership
of is I'm freaking Ashley I've been
there I'm a good mom I'm raising my my
daughters I was married to a cop which I
grew up in that household ashle I know
that's a whole different ecosystem right
like there's not a lot and now I'm
looking for somebody to just
um for like rock on until the wheels
fall off I don't have a good time and so
this is I'm not playing games anymore
and Y A lot of the modern dating is set
up literally like a video game it's a
game yeah right it's a swipe right let's
meet I'm going to give you a thumbs down
emoji or no dude I'm just going to tell
you I'm a hard on my sleeve kind of
person and my promise is that those
people are out there who love honesty
and directness and somebody that's a
little bit whoa that's a lot
right but if you start hedging
yourself you're going to end up in the
same spot
again it's both feet in the bo I think I
I think I did that in the beginning when
I first met my husband I wasn't a lot I
didn't wear my heart on my sleeve and
then when I started to truly become who
I was in the marriage I don't think he
liked
it and that's really hard
right my husband liked a pseudo version
of
me
but I want to back up and say it again
that was an issue with him
right did you give it your all I did
okay you got to let that
go like you're still trying to fix it
now
yeah can't fix it it's over what you can
do is build something else it's red
yeah Fair yep do you want rad what does
rad feel like um laughter I'm not very I
love to laugh I love to be funny I love
to be on adventures I'm a very athletic
so I just love to be out trying new
things I'm
spontaneous that's what I want I promise
you there's guys listening to this
looking at their wives now going GH geez
how do I get in contact with
Ashley okay
M but you just laid out is a dream it's
awesome okay and if you had laid out I
just I'm kind of boring and I'm a nerd I
like to read books and go to bed at 9
o'clock and I don't I like just being
stable there's some guy listening going
yes
right
right it's when you feel yourself um
gosh I'm trying to think uh it's
something extraordinary and it's on the
internet somewhere that beray brown
talked about but about
belonging is
devastating it when a person or as a
person begins to look around and say
okay what do these people need from me
so that I can be
included right and that's dangerous
maybe the word's not belonging but
that's the sentiment when you
start hiding parts of yourself so that
maybe they'll ask me out again that
thing's already that thing's already
sunk man
right somebody hear that somebody's
going to love the dance you do when the
tacos are
delicious okay they are they just don't
yep Fair yep all right hang on the line
I'm gonna send you a copy of uh building
an unanxious life and I want you to read
all the way through it and do all the
exercises in the back you're here's what
you are you are
rebuilding you're rebuilding something
you're rebuilding what how you think of
yourself you're rebuilding your
day-to-day you're rebuilding what a home
looks like you're grieving what you
thought this thing was going to look
like and now it's different you're
rebuilding everything and as any
building project goes you always are
like all right I'm going to get the
foundation down on Monday no you're not
it's going to take like seven days or 14
days or 22 days because it rained one
day it's just going to take a while
that's okay it's all right it's never
forgetting I'm not there may be parts of
me I got to change cool but my Core
Essence the core person who I am dude
I'm not I'm not gonna I'm not gonna put
a lid on that just to try to get
temporary approval because that always
always ends in chaos and Ash and you and
my friend are worth more than that it's
awesome thank you for call you're you're
you're a brave woman
Ashley